hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast a keynote presentation next
generation RNA seek workflows and
analysis we are delighted to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots I am Judy O'Rourke and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Gary schroth gage d dr.
Schroeder is currently a distinguished
scientist at illumina where who directs
the genomic applications group based in
San Diego he obtained his PhD in
biochemistry from the University of
California Davis and has been working in
the field of next-generation sequencing
NGS for 10 years as part of alumina and
celexa in his research dr. Schroth uses
NGS to study gene structure expression
and regulation and applies this to
genomic projects in the fields of cancer
microbiology and infectious disease over
the course of his career dr. stroke has
published 90 peer-reviewed research
papers 17 US patents I will now turn it
over to dr. Schroth for his presentation
thank you Judy it's a pleasure it's a
pleasure to be here and to talk to this
audience about what I'm going to call
next-generation RNA seek so at Judy
mention I've been working in this field
for about 10 years and I'm going to talk
about sort of some of the challenges and
complexity of RNA seek but at the end of
the day I hope to convince you that
actually next-generation RNA seek can be
very
straightforward and very sort of
standardized and so that's what the
that's what sort of the the take home
message from this talk will hopefully be
before I get into some of the technical
details about doing RNA sake I want to
just remind people that the
transcriptome inside the cell is is very
complex we've learned so much about RNA
function over the last 10 15 20 30 years
even and we know now that there are so
many different complex functions at RNA
have in the cell and then we also know
that RNA transcription can be very
dynamic it can go up and down quite a
lot it can vary in tissue to tissue
quite a lot and so there's a lot of
complexity and RNA seek is has turned
out to be sort of the most specific and
unbiased and sensitive tool for kind of
understanding all of the complexity of
the mammalian eukaryotic transcriptome
and so if you look in eukaryotic cells
there are many different RNA
subpopulations there's on the left eye
shows sort of the coding RNAs messenger
RNA and some of those can vary in
expression from even enormously
expressed transcripts more than 10,000
copies per cell and then the sort of
explosion in the RNA world in the last
15 20 years has been in the non-coding
RNA is of course we've known about
ribosomal RNA and trna for a long time
but the whole field of link RNAs and
small RNAs is something that is those
really exploded in the last decade and
so I think that that makes that makes
the the interest in doing RNA seek even
greater for some of these interesting
classes now from a from a technical
point of view you can say that most of
the RNA is over on the left that
messenger RNAs are polyadenylated
although not all there's some very
abundant jeans like histone genes for
instance that are not polident elated
and then and then on the right you can
say that many of these are not palio
dental it gets kind of complicated
because it turns out many link RNAs for
instance are polyadenylated most of the
RNA shown there in red or not
no microRNAs are probably dental ated
but some of the link rnase some of the
more famous link rnase in fact are
probably attentive and this is important
because we as I'll talk about when we do
RNA seek preps we tend to think of
different flavors of the preps some that
use a poly a capture and some that don't
and so when you do that you've got to
keep in mind that you're sort of parsing
up the RNAs that are in the cell in that
way and so the other interesting thing
about studying RNA compared to DNA is
that RNA comes in all kinds of different
sizes and shapes and and it has a
different definitely a different
stability profile than DNA and probably
one of the most interesting and probably
challenging from a technical point of
view is the enormous copy number
variation that that RNA has compared to
DNA and so if you look at that the
transcriptome inside any cell is is as
an enormous tremec range especially when
you look at a population of cells you
know when we look at large amounts of
RNA say hundred nanograms that
represents thousands of cells and so you
basically are detecting you know
generally about 15,000 transcripts
across a large dynamic range that is 10
to the fourth maybe 10 to the fifth
dynamic range of counts that you get
from those and that's what this is here
this is a reproducibility plot of two
preps to RNA seek preps done on the same
sample and then run on two different say
lanes of a sequencer and then comparing
the counts the actual counts and so
that's why you can see the digitization
of data down here at the bottom and and
there's been a lot of debate over the
years as to how much data do you need
for RNA seek you know what do you need
10 million reads or 50 million reads or
500 million reads to do a good rna-seq
experiment and basically just to sort of
point out that the genes at the top end
of this sort of rocketship plot are very
easy to study those have deep coverage
even with a few million reads all the
debate is generally about the jeans down
at the
lower-end in this expression level these
are more challenging to study from
accounting point of view because every
time you collect another ten million
reads probably eight or nine million of
them go to the genes that are at the top
of the pile that are already very very
well studied and so this is a this is
where the dynamic range of the
transcriptome has makes RNA seek a
little bit more challenging to study
some of the things down below in and so
I think that that's that's a
consideration and over the years we have
developed a pretty good understanding of
this for our different preps and we have
very clear recommendations to users as
to what how much are how much how many
reads would be recommended for these
sort of optimal kind of return on
investment of reads versus what you're
getting information content you're
getting out of that and then just to
remind you that of course in in
eukaryotic systems the gene can be
spread out on a chromosome in relatively
large regions of the chromosome so that
an initial primary transcript is made
that is then spliced into potentially
alternatively spliced mature messenger
RNAs and so that's the other interesting
thing we've learned with RNA seek over
the years is that you know depending
upon what type of prep you use if you
use a poly a selection sort of prep
captures only the messages there at the
bottom but if you do something that we
call total RNA seek and I'll talk about
the details of that in a second you got
to remember that you're capturing
everything you're capturing all the
primary transcripts all the introns that
have been spliced out plus all the
messenger RNA and so I love this slide
that Brent greatly from the modencode
project let me borrow this is this is
just to give you a feel for the dynamics
of that goes on in a typical
transcriptome and so this is kind of a
microcosm of that kind of a statement if
you if you look at this what this shows
is brow browser shots of the data
aligned from this is from a Drosophila
experiment and this is just one small
region of one chromosome
in drosophila and then the time points
the different tracks are our time points
of Drosophila embryo development and so
you can just see the data is it what is
what is cool about this is the data is
showing sort of the stranded pneus where
the data is either above the line or
below the line depending upon whether it
maps to the Watson or the creek strand
which is of course is a really nice
feature of RNA seek you get very
explicit details about the Strand that
that's that the transcript is coming
from what I wanted you to see is that
you can see if you look at these genes
how they changed even during the first
24 hours of drosophila development the
gene expression patterns are changing
quite a lot and that is a that you can
just sort of picture that happening all
around our chromosomes at all times in
response to you know circadian rhythms
or what we've eaten or different tissues
whatever this is this is why RNA seek is
so exciting is that basically there's so
much information content that you can
get out and and hope to kind of
understand these dynamic changes so as
I've sort of alluded to if you if you
look at RNA prep are any library prep
there's basically two and now i'm going
to introduce a third a third one today
there's essentially two major preps that
if you look at all of our kits or even
other kits that are sold out in the
marketplace today they basically can
boil them down to two sort of overall
protocols they either capture the
messenger RNA as shown on the left here
where you use usually a bead with the
poly t primer capture the messenger RNA
or they do a method where they
essentially capture the ribosomal RNA
and remove that right off the bat so i
forgot to mention back in the previous
slide but if you just open up a
eukaryotic cell and just took a physical
inventory of all the RNA in there
probably ninety five percent of the
molecules that are RNA molecules in the
cell maybe ninety to ninety-five percent
are going to be ribosomal RNA and so we
like to remove that as much as possible
poly a capture is a very effective way
of removing the
zomo essentially you can think of it as
a rich in for the MRNA but there's also
methods where you can use essentially
probes on beads to remove the ribosomal
RNA as well and then essentially
sequence everything else that we call
total RNA see and so the the advantages
of that are are that like I said we can
get specifically get the messenger RNA
there on the left or we can get the
total RNA on the right we have
introduced a new essentially workflow in
the last couple of years that we call
RNA access essentially this is using
hybrid capture or enrichment sort of
methods like we used in exome sequencing
or another sort of targeted sequencing
to pull out specific genes or specific
regions in the transcriptome that we're
interested in sequencing and so in this
method the way we do it we we don't do a
poly a capture or ribosomal reduction we
take all of the total RNA make a library
out of it add adapters and then we just
capture the parts of the library that
we're most interested in and we've
successfully used this to sequence the
entire exome that's the RNA access
product that we sell right now but we
also have been working on this in sort
of more defined sets cancer gene sets
fusion sets we've even studied viral
rnas with this kind of approach and this
is a this turned out to be very
interesting i'm not going to get a
chance to talk about all those different
variations of that but essentially it
has added a third workflow so our three
main workflows in any RNA prep is going
to be either capture mrna remove
ribosomal or essentially capture
specific regions that you're interested
in uh just to highlight that actually
these these do require different input
amounts all of our standard kits are
will work really well down to 100
nanograms the RNA access kit works down
to 10 nano grams which is which is
interesting that's actually a little bit
lower input and that's because we don't
remove the ribosomal RNA and it's sort
of in there as a such a kind of a
bulking agent there in that middle work
okay this is just a to remind me to tell
you that we we actually have a wide
suite of RNA library prep solutions most
of these I'm not going to talk about
today I'm going to focus in on the true
Sikh stranded mrna and especially a new
incarnation of that and and also just to
just to point out that that is by far
the most common workflow that is used is
is when people think of RNA seek they
generally think of what we're calling
air true sake stranded mRNA which is
capturing the poly a tail and sequencing
the coding messages and also as Julie
alluded to I've been working in this
field for eight or ten years now and
we've been doing what we call RNA seek
for eight years and it has evolved a lot
over the years we have you know as I
alluded to these stranded and non
stranded methods we have new methods
that the total RNA kit methods that I've
talked about we we push these two lower
lower input levels and like I said all
of our standard kits require a hundred
nanograms only 100 and a ground with
kids we developed really good methods
for studying FFP once again I'm not
going to really be able to get into all
of this but I think that that's the
major use case for that RNA access
workflow that I talked about a second
ago is for studying highly degraded RNA
RNA sequencing at the single-cell level
is a widely used method and we were
involved in some of that work early on
and then the other thing that is
important is all the kits that I'm
talking about here are our automated so
all of the automation vendors of the
world beckman t ken hamilton etc i'll
have many of them have automated
protocols available for for using the
true see kids okay so with that is in a
reduction I want to kind of get to the
question is what do I mean by next
generation RNA seek and so I kind of
talked about how there's you know it's
it's relatively complicated in a way
that transcriptome is complicated it's
dynamic
there's lots of choices of of kits to
use etc but in reality most like I said
most users do the MRNA seek the poly a
selected mrna see and so what I want to
talk about is what we've been doing that
alumina to make this whole process
simpler so over the last 10 years we've
made simple sequencing quite simple we
have our sequences are very easy to use
if you kind of look across the entire
workflow from starting with a sample to
getting an answer the sequencing part is
usually the easiest part we have load
and go reagents push-button sequencing
the data easily streamed to either a
local server or to a cloud-based server
like our base base server to do analysis
and so that the sequencing part of the
workflow has been made simple but over
the last couple of years been working on
a new system to try to make library prep
a lot simpler as well and so I want to I
want to tell you about a system that we
call neo prep that really is designed to
make library prep simple and easy to do
and allow it to be sort of reproducible
in any lab that has one of these
instruments that will all be able to do
sort of RNA seek to the same level in
the same standard using this system so I
want to talk a little bit more about
this system so it's it when you order a
kit for this for instance the mRNA kit
that I'm going to talk about you get
everything you need in one kit you just
only thing you have to add is your RN
ace rnase total RNA sample so starting
with total RNA you essentially load it
into a card as I'll show you here and
the kit includes all the buffers and the
agents to do the library prep and
quantification and normalization which
is an interesting feature of this as
I'll describe in a second the libraries
that are created by this system are
completely ready to load onto a
sequencer so the idea is that you
basically
use the the information on the
instrument you place the cartridge into
this this holder here you put this card
on here that sort of directs you where
to pipette you fill it the cartridge
with the reagents and your sample the
whole setup time takes less than 30
minutes usually 15 or 20 minutes after
you've done it once or twice but
essentially your serve loading in all
the reagents into this microfluidic card
if you will and then essentially what
you're going to do is press go say I
want to do an mRNA prep start it up and
completely walk away and come back in in
a few several hours and you'll have 16
mrna seek preps so you load the reagents
you can see the pipette they're loading
in the reagents you essentially press go
confirm the run details start to run and
when the when the run is complete you
essentially collect the libraries from a
sort of a collection portal load them
into a plate and you're ready to go and
so basically this this process
dramatically simplifies the number of
steps involved and the number of
consumables needed and makes for the the
entire process to be more quality
controlled so if you look at this we're
taking it from 60 steps doing it the
manual way down to 10 steps in terms of
doing it on the Neo prep significantly
lower amount of consumables needed in
terms of doing this prep and and what we
think is going to be really interesting
is that it sort of streamlines of
quality control process so right now
every lab sort of quality controls our
library slightly differently this will
sort of standardized that so that all
the library is coming off the meal prep
system will have been sort of quality
controlled in the same manner and so we
are this this system is in early access
right now and it'll be completely
available for commercial release in the
next month or so and the idea here
is that actually just to be thorough I
wanted to just show you that we also
have a DNA prep kit sort of our standard
DNA prep kit as well that has a lot of
interesting features this sort of tells
you the takes about seven half hours to
make the DNA libraries about ten and a
half hours to make the stranded mrna
libraries each cartridge will make 16
libraries at a time the input amount
recommended for our mRNA kit is only 25
nanogram that I'm going to I'm going to
show you some more information about
this so this is technically lower input
than our standard manual kit this is
some background on on the DNA prep just
to let you know that the prep this is or
how we judge the the Neo prep system is
that it should work as well and create
as high quality data as our manual kits
do in general we but at lower input
amounts and that's what we're showing
here 75 nanograms input into the Neo
prep looks identical in all ways that we
can look at it with 200 nanograms of
human DNA going into the manual version
of this kit and so when it comes to RNA
you can see that this this is a this is
an example to look at sort of the
reproducibility and so what we did here
is we took our two standard samples
universal human reference RNA uhr are in
human brain and we put them in every
other laying of the set of the cartridge
so let's say all the out of the 16 Wells
and the cartridge all the odds are you
HR and all the evens our brain and then
this is looking at the final data when
you map it back to the genome and look
at counts and those are all little mini
scatter plots there like I was showing
originally you see that when you HR and
you HR are compared you get a nice tight
scatter plot but when you compare you a
chart a brain you get this sort of
characteristic differential gene
expression plot and so that's that's
that's just showing that essentially all
the the AQ hrs and the eight brains are
very reproducible and so I want to show
you some of the the data we we've been
using during development of this process
to kind of talk about the robustness of
this and and also sort of the
justification for our 25 nanogram
put them out so we look at library yield
a stranded pneus CD of coverage this is
sort of how spiky it is for instance how
even the coverages across the gene
duplicates and percent ribosomal RNA and
so you can see that the yellow bar there
is highlighted sort of our recommended
input amount so we recommend 25 data
grams of total RNA into this cartridge
but I want it but I want to show is that
actually it can this is showing 10 5 and
2 nanograms there to the left of the
yellow bar and all these plots and you
can see that actually it's making really
nice libraries even at 2 nanograms we're
getting enough yield for the system to
quantify and characterize the library at
the end of the process the duplicates do
go up a little bit with with five and
then especially to nanograms indicating
that we actually really are sort of
limiting the number of molecules going
into the prep and so that's probably the
going it up being the floor of this sort
of this sort of approach in terms of the
technology that we have the way that
working today but I just want to show
this to convince you to 25 nanograms is
by far and you know it's it's well above
a sort of a floor a limit so even if
York want is a little bit off and you
throw in 10 or 15 or 20 milligrams it
should still work very well and the
other thing is we wanted to make sure
that the preps that we're doing just
does it like what the DNA the preps are
comparable to the manual preps and so
this is showing a scatter plot of neo
prep data at 25 nanograms versus the
manual process at 100 nanograms you can
see that the reproducibility of the gene
expression counts is very good but I
wanted to just make the point that even
at 10 nano grams compared to manual and
even down to that very lowest amount of
to nanograms actually the libraries that
we're getting out of the Neo pref system
are completely valid they're there
they're very nice libraries as you noted
in the previous slide they will have
slightly higher duplicate levels but
actually in pretty much every other way
there there
behaving quite well as good RNA seek
library so the nail prep system is
important part of our of our ecosystem
part of the concept of next-generation
RNA seek is that we're trying to
simplify this entire process so I've
spent some time talking about the Neil
prep system which sort of helps feed the
sequencers hopefully hopefully you can
appreciate that our sequences are
actually fairly simple to use the Neo
prepon is designed to simplify the
sample prep process and we also have
been spending a lot of time and energy
and effort on improving the downstream
analysis tools and especially the cloud
based analysis in bass bass and so I
want to just have a few slides to talk
about what we what we have there and how
that fits into this complete
next-generation workflow before I get to
that though I want to I want to just
emphasize that Neil prep libraries are
completely compatible with any of our
platform so for instance you could you
could prepare 16 bacterial genomes using
the Nano kit the DNA nano kit and
sequence those on am I seek to
reasonable coverage of all 16 genomes or
if you use neo prep to complete to
create 16 RNA seek libraries that's
actually a good impedance match if you
will with our next seek platform so that
would a give you an average of at least
25 million reads per sample and I'll
show you data using that sort of
workflow in a few slides or if you do
human genome sequencing and you're using
the Nano kit you could do 16 human
genome sequences sequence that on one
run of a high cqx system and to complete
human genomes so that the point of this
slide is a neo prep for various
applications can feed it's actually a
fairly reasonable match at four
different applications for our different
sequencers so I want to say a few words
about the base base RNA seek analysis
applications and so base space is our
cloud-based analysis environment and
what we have there is actually several
applications for doing RNA seek that
we've created plus there are other
applications
they're that other parties outside of
alumina have created for doing RNA
analysis we have a two major workflows
one is shown by the two icons on the
right it's the sense of the top hat
alignment and cufflinks assembly and
differential expression analysis so that
can get essentially all a lot of
information about the transcript I'll
show some of the features of each of
these work clothes in a second or the
the application on the left that we call
RNA express is generally good for just
straight ahead straight forward gene
expression profiling it runs a little
bit faster although as I'll show you in
a second and the cloud speed is not
really that critical of an issue
everything runs fairly fast in the cloud
so but these are really quite easy to
use and if you've never actually tried
them I would encourage you to to open up
a base base account and test these out
we have data sets up there that they're
free to use free to analyze and you can
sort of test them out and see how well
these apps work and what the outputs are
there they're amazingly simple to use
essentially anyone can do these types of
bioinformatics use these types of
bioinformatics tools now with these kind
of data analysis solutions okay so I
want to show a specific example of a
scientist of my group who did an
experiment using the Neo prep system the
next seek sequencer and and the base
base apps where we essentially started
with 16 total RNA samples and went all
the way to fusion calling so RNA fusion
is a hot topic in cancer obviously and
so I want to show example where in less
than three days actually technically
that's in two days you'll see in the
timing here we went from RNA samples to
fusion calling and and i want to show
you how that's possible so to start off
with as i said setting up the nail prep
system takes a maximum of 30 minutes so
essentially if you you start with a
total RNA you load the cartridges was
shown in the those previous slides
you press go and you walk away and do
something else with the rest of your day
instead of monitoring your sample prep
you can that takes about 10 and a half
hours and typically people in my group
sort of set that up at the end of the
day one day and they come back the next
morning and and the libraries are ready
to go then in in certain less than an
hour you can pull those libraries
together load them on to an instrument
like our next seek system that is quite
easy to set up and run so there's
another hour let's say of hands-on time
to start the sequencing run that
sequencing run takes 18 hours for a 2 x
75 base pair run which is what we
recommend for RNA seek and then once
that data is collected it will be
streamed up to the cloud and then once
the run is complete you'll get an email
from our system it will say your rut is
complete and now you can start your base
base analysis and and essentially that
takes literally less than five minutes
to sort of set up a either top hat
cufflinks or RNA express analysis and
like I said that that takes to do an
entire run of next week data it takes
eight and a half hours for the cloud to
analyze those 16 samples and so so
basically what we're what we're talking
about here is you know an hour and a
half essentially of effort hands on time
and 35 hours of essentially clock time
to go from starting RNA to fusion
calling and so I want to show some
examples where we started with these
eight cancer cell lines we've studied
these a lot we've looked at fusions in
them a lot and so they have some nice
positive controls in there if you will
and we did these in replicates on the
Neo prep system so we did to replicate
preps of each of these eight samples to
give us 16 preps the the other
interesting thing about the neo prep
system is at the in the workflow is
integrated into base space so hopefully
you'll be able to read this on your
screen but if you look very carefully
you can see that a
are a scientist in our group Lisa Watson
started this on it's an evening on a
Monday and started the prep came back it
was done the next morning and
essentially before she even came to work
she pulled up her base base account look
the data and she could see that
essentially all 16 of the preps were
good they all have nice status they all
had high outputs they were all sort of
the the system could tell there was
material there it quantified them and
normalized them so that all of the
libraries that you pull off of the Neo
prep system can be normalized to 10 nano
molar and so this is showing how the
system has normalized them and
essentially so before at least even came
to work on Tuesday she could tell that
her library is ready to go and she could
start thinking about when she wanted to
load them onto the next seek system and
so sometimes during the during the day
and on Tuesday she she loaded them onto
the next week and did the sequencing and
the next day she could look at the data
to show like for instance here's the
indexing QC data that shows that without
any intervention at all just taking the
the indexes as they come off of the Neo
prep system you can see it's it's fairly
nice and fairly uniform index
representation in general we get CDs of
indexes of about twenty percent twenty
to twenty-five percent which is about as
good as most labs can do manually
frankly and so the point is without it
without having to do any kind of
quantification of the libraries at the
end of the day the system automatically
does that all's Lisa did is pull the 16
libraries together in equal volumes and
load them on to the next system and this
is sort of the index representation she
got and so this is to remind me to tell
you that the two there are different RNA
seek workflows in our in our base base
environment what Lisa did here is she
ran essentially just the top hat part of
the cup of the top hat cufflinks
workflow those are two separate apps it
does alignment a variant calling and
fusion calling and that's that's what
use to analyze this particular data it
easy to see there's something there are
some differences between RNA Express and
top at cufflinks top hat conflicts being
the more involved and serve a labret
workflow RNA Express is really mainly
used for gene counting so she was able
to get some differential expression this
is just showing sort of two replicates
of thp and hl-60 and you get gene counts
out of this analysis as well and she's
showing sort of differential expressions
or the reproducibility for the mick gene
for instance that is differentially
expressed between these two samples and
you see the replicants are very nice the
differential expression is very nice
there's tools involved in the RNA
Express as you can see here where you
can filter the data based upon fold
change etc and analyze genes that are
that are up or down regulated in your
samples so back to the diffusion story
so basically Lisa Lisa started the just
to remind you that worked the time frame
of this she started the Neo prep run at
seven o'clock on Monday afternoon or
evening the data was that the preps were
done she loaded him on the neck seek on
Tuesday by the time she came to work on
Wednesday she started up the the app
once again on her base base account from
her personal computer at home and saw
that the run looked good she started the
analysis and by Wednesday afternoon and
she was able to create this table and
frankly it took more time to create this
table than it did to actually run the
analysis so you know you had to have to
look through the different different
results that come out of the top hat
alignment and create this table and so
this basically shows the the fusions
that we excuse me know are in these
samples we're easily detecting them in
this in this essentially three day
workflow and this is showing some of the
data you can also take the data out of
the base base app and and insert it into
like I GV or other genome browsers and
you could look at things like this where
this is just showing a clear fusion in
this a431 cell line that doesn't exist
in mcf-7 so long
and so the the what I wanted to try to
leave you with is this this next
generation RNA seek workflow is really
simple reproducible and standard
workflow so this is essentially the
workflow that we are we are recommending
now for the standard RNA seek that once
again seventy to eighty percent of the
users of our systems do standard mrna
seek preps and analysis and so once
again if you if if you have the Neo prep
system everybody has access to the base
base cloud-based analysis these days and
so if you can start with your 16 samples
like I say load them on day one sequence
them on day to analyze them on day three
and essentially a three-day workflow you
can go from starting total RNA to a
fusion detection and this is just some
of the details of what we're doing here
that like I said a 16 samples per run we
had an average of twenty-five million
paired in two by 75 base pair reads
which is sort of what we recommend and
is we sell kits specifically for that
for the next seek system and this is
done with a standard top hat analysis in
base base and so less than three days
from RNA to results and so with that I
would like to thank everybody for
attending this and would like to
entertain some questions and so I see
that some people have put some questions
out to Judy and I so I'm going to pass
the ball back to Judy and see if we can
answer some questions thank you dr.
swirl for that informative presentation
video questions before we get started on
the question and answer session though
I'd like to remind our audience how to
submit questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can my first question is is there a
fragmentation step in the nail prep work
flow so that the question and all that
aggression out on that the question of
whether there is a a fragmentation step
the Neo prep workflow reminds me to tell
everybody that the the nail prep version
of our RNA seek analysis is exactly the
same steps that are used in our in our
standard kit so yes there is a
fragmentation step in the Neo prep work
flow and it's it's exactly the tune to
the same way that our true Sikh kits are
true Sikh workflow are tuned so for the
any of those any of you who have used
our workflow we start with total RNA we
fragment it because we have shown over
the years that the random priming
process is much more uniform and much
more it gives much more even coverage
after fragmentation so the answer is yes
there is a fragmentation step in the
workflow okay is the meal prep scalable
to prepare say 16 targeted panels for
the mosaic so
so so the that question in terms of
scalability of 16 target panels I think
the is an interesting question that
sounds more like a DNA question frankly
and it does remind me to to tell you
that the essentially amplicons
sequencing workflow which is sort of
what I'm thinking of is that the answer
there is going to be it's going to be a
good one a good a good application
essentially what we are doing is
eventually they'll need many of our work
our star standard workflows on to neo
prep the true Sikh custom amplicon
workflow is going to be one of the
workflows that we release over the next
six to 12 months for the Neo prep system
right now we have only the MRNA and the
and the DNA nano but as I said that that
sort of covers probably sixty to seventy
or eighty percent of most of the things
that people do with next-generation
sequencing or those two kids what is
fusion calling okay fusion calling
that's an interesting question i would
say fusion calling is very specific to
cancer and essentially that's the way
you you use RNA seek to look for genes
that have been fused together by a
translocation event that happens at the
DNA level usually in an intronic region
such that two genes that are not
supposed to be transcribed together get
transcribed into one primary transcript
that are in spliced into a fusion
transcript so for instance there's some
very famous examples the Philadelphia
chromosome creates the BCR Abel
transcript which is one of the positive
controls we use in many of our cell
lines and that's a classic cancer fusion
and so that's what I was referring to by
fusion transcripts
well the Neil prep technology be
appropriate for rival minus sample prep
so that's it that's another good
question that's actually again one of
the other protocols that we will be
porting on to the Neo prep system over
the next six to 12 months so as of today
the system only does the MRNA protocol
not the ribose zero or the total RNA
protocol and so the but I would I would
look for that sometime over the next six
to 12 months that we would we would have
that essentially what we call total RNA
seek using the ribose zero technology we
will have some of those kits available
on the Neo prep system as well how
important is the RNA integrity before
library preparation so that's another
really good question that I should have
talked about a little bit more when I
was talking about the differences
between the total RNA prep and the mRNA
seek prep so with mRNA because we are
doing a poly a capture it is really
important that the RNA be very high
quality such that when you grab onto the
poly a tail you essentially capture the
full length mRNA if the RNA is degraded
and you and you use the poly a prep then
you will essentially be capturing just
the three prime end of the transcript
which most people are not that
interested in so that's one of the
biggest advantages between the total RNA
and mrna if you do total RNA and you
just do ribose zero depletion then
essentially we don't have any five
primer three prime bias due to
fragmentation so or degradation so the
ribose zero technology works really well
in cases where the RNA is either
varying qualities say very high quality
and you're trying to study with also low
quality samples or when cases where the
RNA is just all poor quality where the
mRNA protocol really doesn't work very
well so the ribose 0 approach which I
said is sort of coming in the future on
neo prep right now we saw a wide a whole
suite of kits that do ribose zero
approaches I would say the that that
that so so as of today we we we don't
have that available is there another
question yes several of what is the
price of machine and the price of
cartridges so the machine is that the
price the machine is and I'm not going
to give exact prices at the moment I
don't know the exact prices but I think
they the instrument itself is around
fifty thousand dollars and the the price
of these of the cartridges is going to
be these are going to be priced at
exactly the same price as we charge for
the kits in the manual version so for
instance in the DNA nano I think the
price per sample is thirty or
thirty-five dollars in our manual kit
it's going to be exact it's exactly the
same in the Neo prep version which in my
mind is a real terrific bargain because
you're not only are you streamlining the
workflow and saving time and money on in
terms of prep but also just to remind
you that the the system will do this
quantification and normalization so you
really don't need to do a bioanalyzer
trace you don't need to spend time doing
qpcr you really save a lot of time and
money on the
end of the analysis of the libraries as
well so these that the system for both
the DNA and the RNA prep will produce
normalized libraries that are all at 10
nanomolar concentrations and I think
that that is a good good way to think
about it do you need to do a separate
analysis in order to identify mutations
that might be present in the sample
study so if you're looking for mutations
and sometimes people do use RNA seek
information for mutations and I didn't I
didn't mention that but the top hat app
that we have I think has probably the
best variant calling software that's
available in a pipeline like this it
sort of will automatically call all the
variants in the rna-seq data as I
mentioned it also calls fusions which
fusions are technically mutations as
well but in terms of like single based
changes or coding snips etc things like
that or mutations in a cancer sample
those are actually also called by our
top hat app it creates VCF files and you
can export those VCF files and analyze
them even compare them to DNA VCF files
if you know there are their apps out
there that are called DCF compare kind
of apps that are both in base base now
and also out in the in many academic
labs and other labs you can you can use
the base that the top hat part of our
app to to analyze variants as well and I
assume that's what you mean by mutations
I think we have time for a few more
questions I see there's actually quite a
lot of questions related to
an analysis of different species and so
in in bass bass today we we have the
genomes there for human and mouse rat
and several other species that are
available in sort of what we call the I
genomes the exact species whether the
species that you're interested in is is
available for analysis in our base base
app have to sort of log on the base base
and and check the documentation I know
there's a quite a wide variety of
species that are essentially ready to go
for this sort of analysis that I
described here but I I can't also go
through every single different species
so the one final question and I'll pass
it back to Judy to wrap it up here the
other the other question I see is about
de novo assembly and you may have
noticed that in the cufflinks app so it
once you run top hats with top hat which
is sort of alignment cufflinks actually
has a you can sort of click a box that
says ask for de novo assembly and it
will it will essentially perform a de
novo assembly and and do transcript
discovery and report that out also in a
separate file so anybody who's ever used
cufflinks knows the source of output I'm
talking about and that's the other thing
to sort of highlight about the base base
apps they have a lot of interesting
features and a lot of interesting
outputs that excuse me that we have
designed and reports that we think are
useful but also it also has essentially
all the standard outputs that if you've
ever run top hat cufflinks before like
many labs have all the typical outputs
of Bam's and everything else that the
output that the system normally outputs
are available in the base base
environment so I think that I will thank
everybody for their attention and if
there any other questions that have come
through that we haven't had a chance
to respond to maybe we can respond to
them afterwards via email I think
actually this this presentation you can
still submit questions if I'm right Judy
will explain that here at the end but
I'd like to thank everybody for their
attention and for attending our session
and I'll pass the ball back to Judy
thanks to all who had submitted
questions today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 13 2015 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you and this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to Ford that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and information will
be included about closing further
questions see you next time bye